police presence 24-7 this is everyday
reality for Jewish institutions in
Germany the Rowan straße synagogue in
Cologne employs its own security service
as an extra precaution it's here behind
bars and a security checkpoint that the
hot youth club meets Anton Syrian runs
the club his aim is to boost young
people's sense of Jewish identity but he
also wants to help them cope with the
reality of being outsiders it's calm the
seamless oft dizzy towards young woman
you often get strange looks when you say
that you're Jewish and children usually
try to hide their Jewishness though you
don't puzzle thing phoebus and that's
really why we're here to teach them that
they shouldn't do that that they can be
proud of who they are Devon thickeners
businesses the cs niche Markham's oil
tankers yet amidst wrote songs Ankan of
dddi increasing although young people
don't tend to receive open threats they
do experience prejudice mention up tioga
in my own personal you overhear things
here and there and sometimes even my
friends say stupid things like hey Jew
or whatever and talk about big noses and
lots of money then people think that
that's what Jews really look like and so
they think they don't know any and I
find that few people really know what
Jewishness is or who Jews really are as
you would a new bulb food it's a fine
line for many whether or not to reveal
their Jewish identity like here on the
football pitch toss maccabi Kern might
be a Jewish football club but religion
is irrelevant here Jews Muslims and
Christians all of them play on the team
and they wear the Star of David on their
kit but only on the pitch finish its
arms and the Bushido clear gas again and
if I'm walking through a dark alley at
night I'll put a jacket on over it
that's hot i forgot we had a bad
experience at a league game once at the
end people called out Free Gaza and free
Palestine and even bloody Jews and you
want to do what you can to avoid things
like that happening only missing for
buoyant as I was for him now that was
the first such incident for the team in
Cologne so far it hasn't affected their
enthusiasm for the game even if they
have become a bit more cautious off the
pitch